okay okay why don't we go ahead and get
started welcome everyone to our Thursday
conference and we have some guests today
who not only are bringing interesting
information and data to us but also
healthier lunch then we normally have
which is good anyways it's my pleasure
I'm actually just going to introduce
Brian and then have him as they take
part introduce the rest of the team
Brian's been and his team have been
working with the program for a couple
years now when we came to the
realization depth that we need to cover
the topic of healthcare data analytics
more and better about the same time
Brian had introduced themselves to me
and it's turned out to be a great
partnership and actually I believe that
the course is it's no longer a can a
generic course number it actually has
its own course number now which which is
an accomplishment so a Brian Sakura and
his team are from Kaiser Kaiser is a
national leader in informatics in so
many ways not only with their
implementation of epic but also the work
that they do in data analytics and being
a true integrated delivery system have
all of the right incentives that
sometimes private health care settings
don't have to manage their data and
coordinate their care so Brian himself
is I can't remember your exact Senior
Director for data analytics are okay and
he he did his undergraduate work at Pitt
in finance and then he has a master of
Health Administration from Portland
State he also was named a couple years
ago as one of the 40 under 40 people who
are up and coming in the Portland area
who are
under 40 so I won't take any more of his
time I will hand it off to him and then
he can introduce other oh yeah no we've
had yeah we I've already said that so
I'm going to hand the mic back to him
thank you welcome everybody again Brian
Sakura and we're today we're going to
talk about healthcare analytics and
again we're all from kaiser and we'll do
some quick introductions here and but
joining me today we have delilah more
who is the manager of our pharmacy
analytics team at Kaiser Permanente Ryan
Henderson who is managed of our
technical administration and production
support team and the same group with
Vanita who recent graduate of this
program and is our information analyst
supporting continuing care services
which is olive kaisers home based
programs so hospice home health wound
care primary care at home and I'm
probably missing a few skilled nursing
yeah and we have Tom Gant tom is an
information analyst supporting our
utilization management programs and our
sunnyside on westside hospitals and
Terry Stetzer who is a business systems
analyst on our production support team
and works to support all the system that
we use within the team on a daily basis
so we're going to talk about today is
basically i'll open things up we're
going to talk a little bit about
analytics and healthcare and we're going
to highlight some analytical roles and
skills to be successful in those roles
for all of you if you're thinking about
going into this as a career specialty
and we'll finally at the end we're going
to wrap up with a panel discussion with
the analyst themselves which would
really be open time for you to ask any
questions you want them day in the life
I mean whatever it's that'll be your
time and finally well the time at the
end we'll hang out if you want to talk
have any questions at the end of the
session as well
so I get asked a lot is like well what
is analytics is like and really I I look
at is basically it's a it's a systematic
use of data to discover business
insights I think that's really the key
pieces like we at Kaiser Permanente are
very fortunate in this field because we
we have the world's largest and most
complete civilian medical record system
in our hands and so we have data a
complete set of data not just like slice
of data for 11 million covered lives
spanning now upwards of 10 years and
it's growing every single year so from
that perspective is like we use we use
our medical record system plus our care
our coverage our benefits or contracts
our financials to really use that data
in a systematic way to help drive the
organization forward our goal is always
to get the right information to the
right hands of our leaders so that they
can make appropriate decisions for
strategic planning purposes for care
delivery treatment plans budget
forecasting staff scheduling you name it
we pretty much cover it analytics would
be descriptive predictive or
prescriptive the bulk of the world still
lives in the descriptive land we're
trying to push our organization more
more into the predictive land I don't
think we're quite into the prescriptive
space yet we have had some successes on
the predictive front we it's a major
focus of our year coming up ahead of us
which we'll talk about a little bit
later and finally analytics to me it
includes data analysis data integration
metric Design reporting dashboard
scorecard so that user presentation
layer Business Intelligence Platform so
we'll talk a little bit some of those
tools exploratory predictive analytics
text mining text mining we can also
bucket voice mining and pushing into the
future image mining as well and it's
also I think this is important aspect as
well it's training education so what we
deliver we have to make sure the
organization can use so a big part of
our role is not only delivering
quality sound product but making sure
that the decision makers in the
organization our physicians our nurses
our managers supervisors vice presidents
know how to use what we're giving them
as well so a big part of what we do in
our world is that training and education
components as well so with that in mind
from a from the analyst perspective I
think there's three key components to
analytics and it's really this is all
around connecting people to information
the 1st for the 1st Corps bucket of
skills I've you for as an essential to
be a successful analyst is programming
skills and you have to know how to work
with data for us inside Kaiser our main
two languages that we use are just plain
old sequel and we use SAS sequel and SAS
seem to be two of the mainstays sequel
you can you leverage inside cognos you
can leverage it inside business objects
there's many tools you can sequel is
embedded inside but is like sequel is
one of the foundational languages of
data analytics SAS is one of the leading
platforms in the healthcare industry so
if you have the opportunity to learn SAS
or poke around them sacem as students
and educators you typically get free
access to SAS through their website
that's one of the foundational tools as
well to extract data from multiple
sources in a great data and then I'll
finally get the point where it can
actually analyze the data typically find
about eighty percent of the work isn't
that extract and cleaning up and then
once you get to that point the analyzing
is the 20 the really fun part is about
twenty percent of the effort is like the
hard part is getting an extracted and
organized critical thinking skills are
very it's the second component of I've
view as a three foundational pieces and
you can be a great programmer but if you
don't have critical thinking skills
you're not going to produce valuable
insights you're not going to be very
effective inside your organization so
what I look at for that is methodical
approaches the complex problems and I
think in the question to answer you can
ask them these guys like some of the
gals some of the problems they face on a
daily basis like they could be big
gigantic prob
like how do we contain the cost of
specialty drugs like weird even start
with that is like so if if you you can
approach those problems you have to
approach from a very methodical mindset
in order to make progress and deliver
results to the organization because it's
not it's like you're boiling the ocean
and finally communication skills I think
the third key pillar is like you can be
a great programmer you can have very
strong critical thinking skills but if
you if you don't have the ability to
translate that information to the
receivers of it the people need to act
upon it is like the value of your
insights will not be realized so the
combination of program and critical
thing and communication skills are what
makes like I think that's like the magic
34 to be a strong analyst and the
communication piece is like it's like
the hardest to train is one of the most
difficult we we have inside the
organization that's why I talked about
the last slide is like that education
training component is so important for
us as well because some of what we do if
you're you're developing a predictive
model or a regression model or even just
a metric or a dashboard is like it takes
a lot to explain how to digest what's on
that piece of paper on that screen to
the decision maker going to pause any
questions so far if you do have
questions hit the button when you ask it
I was supposed to remind you of that so
analytics in healthcare is I think you
can find analytics spread through every
aspect of healthcare organizations and
at high levels I think the big buckets
are they we leverage analytics to
improve our clinical effectiveness are
improved member satisfaction we leverage
analytics to improve operational
efficiency which goes to the
affordability component and we leverage
analytics for it financial and
administrative performance and for us
inside our organization is largely on
the health plan side of Kaiser from a
clinical quality perspective improving
the quality of care is like you you
can't improve what's not measure
I mean I think I said just across the
board we we have had initiatives in the
past where like one of our major 2015
successes was we closed our colorectal
cancer screening gap between the Latino
population and our average population by
providing the right metrics and reports
to our case management program we closed
that gap in less of one year that was
that would not have been achievable
without our analysts working with the
case management program leaders to
provide them with the information they
needed one to know who to target but two
to give them metrics to monitor
performance I think that's a good
example of how you can drive real
meaningful change using data and
analytics in the clinical setting from
an so um one of its a great point that
you just made about if it's not measured
you can't improve it but there's also
has to be a cultural change or a
paradigm to get buy-in to get those
measurements so for the example you just
gave how much was stuff that was already
really already being collected versus
you needed additional resources to
collect the data that your analysts
would need to make the decisions or to
be able to model the data you know it's
we're fortunate because in a lot of
cases we have the data it's it's being
collected somewhere it might be
collected in a primary care visitor
through an urgent care visitor out of
one of our nurse advice line it's the
data is there it's just very disparate
and if you don't have a way to pull it
together and look at it through the
right lens it in it's there but at the
same time if you don't look at the right
way it doesn't exist it's like so for
that for the decision makers it needed
to act upon it we were the ones that
pulled that data together and gave them
the metrics that allow them to act upon
it but it all existed inside the
organization somewhere
oh there are times as an analyst that
you get pulled onto a project to measure
how well how much of an impact it's
making but they're not everything that
they're trying to measure is stuck in
free text so part of your job might be
to inform the person that's customizing
the system to say please filled out a
field that we can use to collect this so
I think sometimes it's a back-and-forth
where you're also informing them to
modify the system so that you can
collect something discreetly in track it
ideally it's already there but it isn't
always a good place to raise that sorry
but I can't resist so if it isn't free
text it's there it's not structured and
obviously there's confidence issues
around that but that is the opportunity
then for NLP or other aspects which I
know would be resources is it actually
more efficient internally just to have
them start collecting structure and you
feel and start collecting or to actually
invest in some of those methods to
extract it in my mind it depends on the
purpose of what you're trying to do if
you're trying to create a list report or
you're trying to create them like if
you're trying to get information in the
hands of the case manager you're trying
to create a metric to monitor
performance structure the structure
drops the way to go if you're looking
for an exploratory you're doing
exploratory or segmentation analysis is
like the text weeds and successful using
text mining techniques for the type of
purpose yeah and sometimes when you
force it to be captured discreetly then
you can report it back on the front end
of the system too so there's reporting
tools which we don't do a lot with but
you can you know with an epic creator
reporting workbench report that's
pointing to that discrete field as
opposed to if you're mining the text
there's not much that the front-end can
really do too to summarize that on the
operational front I think a lot of the
focus is around workflow throughput like
staff scheduling are we making the most
of our resources are we moving people
through the hospital in an appropriate
way like measuring and trying to
minimize time between discharge order
and actual disk
surgical on time starts it's a lot of a
lot of our focus on operational
effectiveness is on patient flow through
the organization and then finally the
financial front is like there are
aspects of utilization management making
sure the right care for the right person
the right setting and supplies and it's
especially surgical supplies drug
supplies are incredibly expensive risk
management and fraud and abuse or off
targets for analytics on the financial
side I'm inside Kaiser is like I you'll
have this in your slide and this is our
the summary of our data and analytic
strategy that we we're we drive towards
on the top half of the arc is really the
content areas that we view as our focus
is a population health is a major focus
delivering actionable insights to the
operations of the organisation
demonstrating Kaiser Permanente's value
to the community and our employer groups
at transforming our care delivery
settings so this pushes us into the
virtual care world we were introducing
video visits to all 35 specialties
primary care urgent care this year
analytics will be a major part of how we
measure that because no organization in
the country is deployed on that scale
and we're going to so we have to figure
out like we have to guide the
organization on how do we respond what's
the right number of visits like how do
we schedule it's it's a pretty cool
stuff on your you don't have a precedent
to follow and finally we continue to
drive on advanced analytics and
innovation and which is a one of our
major themes for the year as well the
bottom half is kind of what I have to do
every day which is governance making
sure you have the right resource making
sure we have the right people making
sure that we maintain the products we
have and trying to coordinate all of
this inside a very large and complex
organization with that opening I'm going
to turn the floor of the Rhine and
Delilah we're going to talk about a
little bit of our the four analyst roles
we have inside the organization and then
apply them to some of the projects we've
just finished in 2015 are planning for
2016
hello hopefully you guys can hear me
alright so some of the analysts rules we
have we have four really distinct
analyst roles and it would eat out
within each one of those roles we have
four different levels right now so the
way these kind of look is if you look at
information analysts those are really
more of the business facing they sit
within the care delivery areas you sit
within finance they sit within the
operational aspects they're really
working one-on-one with the business
partners understanding the daily needs
gathering requirements building out ad
hoc analysis that kind of thing from
there would go into like the data
analysts these are the guys that are
doing a lot of the foundational builds
for data Mart's etl work using
informatica Oracle SAS as examples
building those those real robust
infrastructures Brian talked a little
bit about the eighty percent twenty
percent if we spent eighty percent of
our time gathering the data the more we
can get into structured martes and
getting business rules agreed to bought
off on and embedded into those marks the
more time we can spend on the analytical
piece so trying to improve that twenty
percent range ideally right we'd be able
to flip it so we spending twenty-four
seven time finding the data and doing
eighty percent of the time doing the
analysis on it from there it goes to
like the report analyst report Alistair
really the presentation layer they take
those structured data marts and prepare
the reports for large distributions I
can't report those kinds of things
they're dealing with cognos they're
using SAS they're using crystal reports
primarily as the main tool and dabbling
into tableau the business systems
analysts there's really two ways to kind
of look at the business systems analyst
the way we use it is really to support
the systems that the rest of the
analysts use so when we have talked
about it Oracle informatica SAS we're
running on a national shared platform so
we might be doing work for the Northwest
we're running on a platform that's based
in California or Maryland or you know
it's quite a widespread within the
Kaiser area so that team does a lot of
the content migration work coordination
with the National ite groups on system
configuration making sure all the tools
are working appropriately those kinds of
things so that's kind of an overview of
the four different roles so within each
role there's four levels so if you have
a highway to the high level look at it
is a level one would kind of the
entry-level production support type role
being able to manage and run the current
content a level two would be able to do
everything the level one is doing but
getting into doing some white
remediation work or enhancement work on
some of that existing content level
three is really being able to develop a
new solution from beginning to end and
then a level four would be setting
standards and applying those standards
to the rest of the analysts throughout
the group and just to add on the level
four that's typically our lead role so
in addition to the technical expertise
you're also serving as a mentor for the
rest of the team helping to train up and
helping your level ones your level twos
mature up to the level three and looking
for integration points across the four
roles yeah so each of the four rules
contains an aspect of the other ones so
they do cross a lot they do work
together a lot and we do have examples
of members of the team moving between
the different roles going from what
reporting analyst to gain an angle a
straight to business systems analyst or
over to an IA depending on their area of
interest in focus so that was kind of a
high-level look at any questions on the
rules clarify to be so it's four roles
in terms of that are up on there but
then when you say levels is it a level
within each role or the roles themselves
are hierarchical until you're moving
from data analyst report analyst well
good question is so it's level within
each role so there'd be a data analyst
one two three four are a 12
okay this may make it a little more
clear that they are kind of stand-alone
role I mean like Ryan said we we have
had people that have moved across and
that's just because maybe they're more
they've got more technical expertise and
they're more interested once they start
getting into a role they realize oh well
actually maybe a BSA is more up my alley
so this slide just kind of provides a
little bit more detail yes yes so I mean
thinking of this from the standpoint of
an of an academic program do do people
come into these roles with different
backgrounds or where do people come in
with a sort of generic background and
then kind of specialized once they're on
the job into these sorts of role it's
kind of been a mix so some will come in
specialized into certain areas others
will come in with more of a broad
background you know kind of different
person to person we try to to make sure
where we look at the team as a whole
trying to you know fill in the gaps that
kind of thing we're not trying to
necessarily get the exact same person
then every role but trying to get more
of a broad view of things and yeah
we look for the basis of those three and
if someone has a solid foundation
trained on gorgeous super strongly
critical thinking in
but yeah I mean we do actually have a
pretty diverse range of academic
backgrounds on our team you know
anywhere from physics probably in social
sciences anthropology I was kinesiology
and I like analyzing my data in my ph.d
program so yeah a few graduates of this
program but yeah it really depends and
if you like you know your analytically
oriented then could be is hit a bigger
each of these teams here so in total our
department is roughly sixty analysts if
you kind of break it up across these I
think there's maybe four so business
systems analyst there's probably 12 10
to 12 in the RA and da space with the
majority of the I a space and that seems
to be the growing area right now and the
reason we have so many is because those
are the business focused analyst so we
have them living out in pockets of the
organization so there's just a lot the
other ones are a little more we call
them like a-kor so they support a lot of
the core functions in our department and
then the ones that are kind of embedded
in operation because we have so many
different areas to support
okay so you've gotten kind of an
overview of what those types of roles
are we wanted to highlight some of our
successful projects from 2015 just to
give you an idea of the type of work
that our analysts are doing so one of
the projects we had an information
analyst partner with our we call it our
TMC the regional telephonic medicine
center so what was happening with this
project is they were not capturing the
information discreetly enough I think we
were doing some mining of the text more
or less to provide the reporting in that
space but it wasn't providing the right
information to our decision makers so
our health connect team which is the
Kaiser eyes version of epic we call it
health connect so our analysts partnered
with our health connect application
coordinators they created a smart form
that was specifically used to track the
RTMC workflow and so an outcome of that
project was we have a really
nice-looking dashboard now that senior
leadership is looking at and we can see
you know information that was kind of
hidden to the the leaders before so the
second one is actually a project that's
going on in my team with the the tableau
experiment and Brian mentioned tableau
we're kind of just starting to dabble
with tableau it's really cool tool to
use so we're using it in our pharmacy
space to look at our high cost specialty
drugs so that's really one of the area's
4 2016 than our organization is focusing
on reducing the cost of our high cost
specialty drugs how can we kind of
contain our spend and space because it
just keeps growing so this tableau
dashboard gets our leadership the
opportunity to drill in you know and
they can see okay this biologics
category is really expensive what is
really driving that and so they can
drill in to see the specific drug and
then even underneath that which witch
doctors are prescribing that drug so
that the pharmacist can partner with the
doctors to make some changes
segmentation models so yeah we've used
advanced analytics to try and understand
where we're losing our members so we've
used statistical methodologies to
predict who's terminating by choice and
so if we can come up with
characteristics that are similar in that
population then we can use it to try and
you know prevent future membership loss
for for imaging we we've had an imaging
data Mart for a little while the ia that
supported imaging actually was part of
the business and that part of the dime
team this year we actually were able to
rule that role in two dime what that
allowed us to do is actually get more
information back on the uses of the data
and what the business was looking at
there was also leadership changes in
imaging so they were changing the way
they were looking at things and so what
we were able to do is gather that
information and we're going through the
process of making enhancements to our
underlying martes to be able to add
flexibility to the ad hoc requests so in
the span of June to December we had
probably 40 plus ad hoc requests out of
imaging for data that wasn't available
within our cognos smart what our plan is
is by adding in I think it's about seven
or eight different data elements will
now be able to handle at least eighty
percent of that as a self service type
mythology so that shift of the eighty
percent to gather twenty percent
analysis this is kind of a prime example
of that so can I ask you a question when
you say imaging what type of imaging are
we talking about and are you really just
analyzing the metadata around the images
or are you actually pulling features
from the images or how is it being used
in an Alexa Kaiser right so it's not the
actual we're not analyzing the images
themselves this is around the members
use of the images looking
MRI ultrasound cat scan those kinds of
things looking at utilization as a
primary utilization by members of
utilization by your clinical teams both
yeah and just to call out and Tom
actually was involved with utilization
management metrics data so when I pass
the mic over for the when we open it up
I'll let him speak to that project
because it's pretty cool yeah the
interior was involved in the Java code
so we try to improve the process as much
as we can some of the stuff we have
control over some of it we don't but we
try to look at different ways to
automate right that's our main goal is
to try to automate as much as possible
to reduce errors to reduce turn time to
make the data more accurate and
available quicker so i can let Terry
talk a little bit about what they did
around the java peas quick question some
of these projects seems to be patient
oriented to make outcomes better some of
them seem to be more establishment base
so that they can reduce costs and so it
was like the example you said with
partnering with the doctors to reduce
the high expensive drugs how do you
balance like patient care and like costs
of care and also overall as an analyst
should be our job to make that decision
or as a higher level and that's yeah the
demand just never ends but I'm basically
what we do is we work very closely with
the leaders of the organization in this
case of a lot of the folks that set our
priorities are the physician Chiefs over
our population strategy group they're
the administrators of our hospitals it's
our chief financial officer and it's a
conversation with them as to what's what
are the priorities what's most important
and it's we always make sure we try to
we're using our limited resources on the
most important work but that is spread
it is spread across the
patient care realm is spread across like
the operations management function the
insurance function and finances and so
it's a it's balanced we have folks that
are pretty much dedicated in each of
those areas so it's a good it at the
same time we have to cover all bases one
thing I just wanted to add because i'm
not sure if it was really touched on but
a big part of what our department does
so Brian mentioned the mountains of data
that we have so it's really you know and
Ryan mentioned automation so one of the
big pushes that we try as a department
is to organize our data in a way that we
can create a self-service kind of
framework for our customers so we're not
always oh can you pull this as an
analyst you know coming to us to ad hoc
meet the need all the time we want to
establish that infrastructure that they
can pull themselves we had their 60
analysts on our team we had in 2015 we
had just over 200 12,000 self-service
reporter analysis under our cognos
system which are people are just
wondering is the 60 analyst for like the
Pacific Northwest for Portland for all
Julia how like what is the region so for
the most part it's for the Northwest
region we do so part of the automation
and the Cognos pieces we talked about we
recently expanded our finance reporting
to cover colorado region as well so we
do have some examples of where we share
our infrastructure shared our reporting
and stuff so common set of reports the
same governance structure so that way
they're getting there's collaboration
between the two regions on what works
being done in the finance space to move
forward
one of my project Kaiser wide that's a
big deal ok you say you said it very
calmly but that's if that's a really big
oh I was curious if you have if you are
currently or if you have planned to
integrate other kind of non-traditional
data types of genomics information if
that's coming into the clinical make
order patient reported outcomes or
environmental
sure so that's a the answer is yes plus
some more I think we it's part of what I
mentioned they are emerging Enterprise
analytic strategy it's it's part of that
work and we have a very large the
largest on the west coast from what I
understand a very large Hadoop server
farm that is being built that them will
be our new big data platform for
everything is either forward so one
thing I want to kind of point out is
we're talking about this stuff and
Kaiser the thing again I think think
about is scale and so for the Northwest
where is that roughly 17 medical office
buildings we've got two full Kaiser
hospitals we've got 10,000 plus
employees when we start looking across
all the different regions we've got
almost 40 hospitals across the entire
Kaiser program 600 plus medical office
building so when these things are being
built with the tools or testing for like
a specific example that kind of thing
but then the next step is really
understanding how to scale that and that
gets to be tricky at times when you're
looking at different installations of
some of the software the tools and
trying to standardize that kind of stuff
okay so this slide just gives you kind
of a preview of some of the projects
that we have planned for 2016 so one
area our population health team is
working on building out an
infrastructure that's going to allow for
cognos reporting so that self service
capability you would think by now we'd
have something but this is kind of a new
area for our organization to build out
the self service capability and the idea
what that is to provide reporting so we
have an on-site wellness component to
our population health programs so we go
out to our employer groups and set up
shop on site and you know they do blood
pressure screenings and you know address
certain care gaps so we're creating this
infrastructure that's got all the
information that could be readily
available to our clinical staff when
they're doing these on site wellness
events for our employer group reporting
quality initiatives and some of our
community benefit programs so we have
driving schools some really cool program
is where we're out in the community
partnering with organizations so this
population health data is foundational
to support those programs I don't know
we're doing some work I don't want to
seek for this so the state of Washington
pass and all payer claims database
legislation I believe in 2014 but
implementation is taking place is here
so as we have members in Washington and
it was in the news recently we're
merging with group health so group
health will become Kaiser Permanente in
the Seattle area we are participating
with the state of Washington in the
rulemaking process to make sure the all
pair claims database and has the right
and particularly for us is like we have
to make sure that in integrated care
delivery system and encounter based
system not a claims based system can be
accurately represented in such a
database so we're very active in
rulemaking right now which involves a
lot of trips to Olympia and will soon be
writing code to make sure our
submissions are done as that process
unfolds that's it are you guys involved
with the organ yes pero very involved we
have a similar challenge with Oregon
right now where it's a claim space
system and we're an encounter based
system so we're working actively with
the OHA on that process and I sit on the
technical advisory board for the apac
group and represent us on a we have near
weekly conversations with OHA on that
from you some of the other projects has
some of the more exciting ones that
involve kind of the predictive analytics
space are within the hospital so we're
looking for some near real-time hospital
demand and throughput so that our I
guess they can better staff based on you
know the real time data needs so we pull
reports and we can tell you what
happened yesterday but being able to
leverage the information that same day
to you know be able to make a decision
about who needs to come into work to
make sure that our hospitals are staffed
appropriately
also we're venturing into some new voice
analytic software which we're looking to
do some data mining with which is going
to be really cool so that's an exciting
one rolling out and then some impatient
staff productivity benchmarking so that
actually yeah so it so at the hospital
for the last four years or so we've been
doing benchmarking with a tool call of
action align so it's true truvin is
their provider what we're looking at is
actually expanding that out under the
primary and specialty care areas and so
with the project about the real time
demand and hospitals I was curious so I
know with the emergency department
information exchange like is that data
been helpful in your shop right now I
hope that is helpful for clinicians that
wondering like your interaction yeah
we're actually we can actually use the
new ed system differently than most
organizations because we have like we're
closed network organisation so for us it
it actually allows us it alerts us real
time when any Kaiser Permanente member
is admitted to an emergency room
anywhere in organ and we talked about
the regional telephonic medicine center
earlier it's pretty much our doctor
command center so whenever we see a
Kaiser member admitted to any Hospital
in the state of Oregon the physician
from the RTMC will reach out to that
hospital and begin care coordination so
that we can make sure that the care is
won't one that the members patient has
stabilized but then that the care is
delivered to permanently medical
standards that's actually great we heard
about Susan otter from the state was our
speaker here a couple weeks ago and told
us about it and it's fascinating that
that you guys can make use of it and and
I mean it demonstrates the value of
information and informatics and
analytics when when the care model
changes in a fee-for-service setting you
know you come in the emergency
department they bill whoever your payer
is and so forth but for you guys as
integrated delivery system it's really
important that money
not be wasted in another emergency
department and so it's interesting the
other hospitals don't like it because we
bring our members back as fast as we can
and and Tom and his team are looking at
leveraging the ED data we can we want to
get it into our data warehouse because
if we can get into the data warehouse we
think we can create some leading
indicators of ed use right which right
now is typically lagged about six weeks
and we think we can get edu straight
leading indicators down the same day
with the ED data we can use it so kind
of piggybacking on that with um the pre
manage that's coming out also kind of
you know piggybacking on Eddie do you
see that as being useful as well since
that will be reaching out more to the
primary care clinics and such or do you
think that you kind of already have a
handle on that because of being
integrated our primary care is largely
all in house where it might with our
recent Eugene expansion it might come
into play a little bit in Eugene because
we don't have a big capital footprint in
Eugene yet but by and large the main
part of our service area all of our
primary care service really is too um
you may not be able to meet name it but
is it something akin to voice face the
voice analytic software they're using
it's it's called nice nice and I don't
know what it stands for i think it's an
acronym but nice is a nice software that
what you're using this for speech
analytics or interaction yes so
basically the way it works is are we
have some very large call centers we
have an appointing call center we have
the nurse advice line we have the rtm
see we have a membership services call
center and our theory is we get
thousands of calls every day so like if
you take residents of beaverton school
district for example we can geotag all
of our members we know who works what
Kaiser members are teachers of Beaverton
what students go to beaverton OR Kaiser
members is like we think we can use like
the nice software to like mine all of
those phone calls and say if we sense a
flu outbreak occurring at beaverton we
can alert them and say hey we got a lot
of calls from people in your area we
think you're about to have a pig flu
outbreak that's our theory at least of
how we can use some of the stone system
data
hmm in terms of the information that
you're gathering from say epic how much
of it is built out using smart data
elements and one of the projects
mentioned smart forms how much of it is
using things that are kind of
foundational or come with the foundation
installation of FX so that's a great
question and I would say actually Kaiser
Northwest was one of the first adopters
so we've done substantial customizations
to our system which is good and bad
because that means that we can't
leverage a lot of the out of the box
epic products as is because we have
created a lot of smart forms smart data
elements it's kind of bittersweet I've
analyzed a lot of the data from our
smart eight elements and it can get a
little bit messy though it is a quick
and easy way to make something discreet
when otherwise it might have been free
text so I would say yes we do and
especially speaking from the pharmacy
perspective we use them a lot for
tracking our disease management programs
our outreach just you know it's an easy
way for someone to build in was the
outreach you know different I guess we
use them a lot for tracking productivity
also so yeah I would say we use them a
lot
so as far as the enterprise wide project
goes how much is being shared now
nothing now it'll-it'll it's it's in
formation pace air rejoin right don't
you sometimes share with California oh
yeah I thought you were talking with him
with the public is like it no it's still
yeah within the no okay with them within
the organization I mean it is there's
representatives from the entire
representatives from all aspects the
organization participated but right now
you're not sharing Oh your citation oh
okay yes we do share sharing is a bit
challenging because like we are on a we
are on epic we have Kaiser Permanente
has standardized on epic but due to our
size and when we put when we installed
epic in the early 2000s there was no
technology available that would allow us
to build a single instance of epic so
inside Kaiser Permanente we actually
have I believe it as 14 instances of
epic across the organization so we have
a core build but then there is as you
can imagine with 14 instances there is
variation so it doesn't that hinders us
our ability to purely share and on the
analytic side we're heavy users of sass
and cognos some we haven't standardize
on our analytic tools yet because the
organizations in the process of going
through that to some more some regions
use Business Objects I'm you sass so
I'll use cognos I'm use tableau and that
crystal report so that hinders us as
well at this point so my question is
really for all of you if reflecting on
our students are there any classes that
are training that you wish you'd had
coming into the role that you have now
hi there i think i graduated this
december from the program so they could
talk about it I think the like Brian
said we extensively used sacem sequel
and also every excel
for anak analysis doesn't have you good
back on them database is really really
good SAS this has built on a lot of
programming especially object-oriented
programming if we have SAS training as a
part of statistic here at its data so
when I went to Kaiser Kaiser I underwent
two trainings for cells so looking if we
have sass as a part of difficult or as
an option when I took the SATs did the
six program here the professor actually
allowed me to press give some answers in
stata as well as SAS at what that kind
of it flexibility was really good
digital analytics program that happens
here every summer is really good because
I think a lot of well if somebody is
coming from a business background like
me who don't have what is who don't have
a knowledge about voice healthcare data
altec I think that program was really
helpful the only program that dr. Hirsch
has given is really good because when
you're going to a program like Kaiser
you really want to know what are the
different confidence of health care so
that was highly useful medical decision
making and if that was though I'm not in
medical decision-making against the
framework that was taught there's really
important the probabilistic decision
making those kind of stuff I guess we do
you may be in the background but I think
it's a very good framework for thinking
critical continuously
I think the java programming classes
been good because they definitely give
you a framework in terms of
understanding sets yeah I would agree
with the need to definitely the SAS
sequel skills are useful very useful and
I also think anything you can do to
enhance your skills and working with
business partners because I think one of
the man information analysts and one of
the real unique aspects of that job is
that we are working with people in
operations so we might be working with a
nurse manager or someone like that who's
requesting data and we need to be able
to explain the data to them in a way
that they'll understand it and then
we'll at the same time they may ask for
requests for data and we need to go back
to someone in our department with strong
technical technical skills and they'll
help us actually extract that data if
we're having difficulty with it so we
have we're communicating with a lot of
different people with different skill
sets and so I think I would say just
your consultative skills of working with
business partners and I think I think I
don't know if a class exists that
actually does that but I think just you
know working with groups collaborating
with others and just understanding how
others are approaching a problem and
kind of guiding your instruction or if
you're trying to train someone on
something trying to guide your
instruction towards how that personal
best understand it there's one more plus
the healthcare quality class by dr.
Dorian okay so for me is a business
systems analyst the two classes that I
wish I'd taken is one collaboration
techniques would have really helped a
lot since i'm trying to get diverse
areas to work together and another one
is is proper documentation when you're
working with a lot of technical people
they just sort of put things down but
you have to translate that into a
language that the business partner
understands so learning how to translate
IT jargon into a plain English document
takes real skill I think I'm getting
more places than my mind there's clearly
the information systems that I guess for
me dr. Mohan thought was really good and
we had an epic class we have epic
practical class that was I guess really
helpful because we do do that back yeah
this is actually this is really good you
may not know this wakes he have a
faculty retreat tomorrow where we're
discussing how we're going to revise our
curriculum along these lines at what
about some of the newer Big Data kind of
things like non sequel databases some of
the you know analytical techniques that
people apply to Big Data has that
impacted you I mean your data certainly
sounds big but in some ways it's very
traditional kind of clinical health care
data yeah we have large volumes of data
but I wouldn't say it's big data in the
pure big data sense of the world I think
at least within our organization there
we are we have use case in pilot
programs in place on how to leverage
more of the with data that can't data
reaches beyond relational databases but
it is not yet reached a point of broad
scale adoption I would guess were within
a few years we will be tipping into that
point especially with some of the work
going on the investments being made in
the organization but I think we're still
we lose large volume data I mean
hundreds of millions of Records tables
of hundreds of millions of records in
them but I'm not necessar still it still
fits within the table
no but ok the question was what's the
role of Hadoop in our future I right now
is like we we live in an environment
where we have most organizations have a
data warehouse we have probably over a
dozen data warehouses so and data Mart's
coming out of our ears so the vision for
Hadoop is that we will we can land data
in Hadoop once and it can be used from
Hadoop for any analytical purpose it's
and the architecture the architecture
can be done in a way that we don't have
to architect specific data Mart's over
and over and over again so I we viewed
as a way to increase the throughput of
the analytical community and quite
frankly save a lot of dollars that we
spend today on servers and database
maintenance
another question
yes um wrapping up a first off a
shameless plug we have several open
positions on our team right now and we
have if Delilah is recruiting an
information analyst for our pharmacy
services we are recruiting information
analyst for inpatient continuing care
services we are recruiting a business
systems analyst for our member
administration area and the insurance
side we have two data analyst positions
open on our development and regulatory
teams and our summer internships which
we always have two to three on the team
will be posting in late March and my
final shameless plug is our data
analytics course it's we are an official
course now no longer kind of a
experiment but we will it is
co-sponsored by Kaiser Permanente and
ohsu of myself and Delilah will be up
here teaching again this summer and the
on-campus week is August 22nd through 26
so grab some of us if you want to learn
more about the course if you have any
other questions we will hang out for a
few minutes you can ask us individually
or say hi and otherwise thank you for
attending to have found this valuable
you